sa vie ses échecs ses parts à 6 ans
après tout un automne en résidence à
l'olympia pour roder son spectacle à
préfère novembre c'est un louis josé
houde au sommet de son art est monté sur
scène hier soir par le passé il a abordé
l'avortement avec beaucoup de
sensibilité dans ce spectacle le
renouvelle l'exploit en traitant de
consentement une réussite d'autant plus
grande en cet automne marqué par les
allégations d'inconduite sexuelle
j'ai jamais été dans une situation dont
monsieur donc été facile donc on
s'entête et un non c'est pas ta faute et
non concertée non consenti l'humoriste
prête de la quarantaine qu'il vient
d'atteindre de racisme d'homophobie
toujours avec un sens aigu du détail son
numéro en hommage aux mères
monoparentales a fait crouler de rire le
public et représente un des moments
forts de la soirée n'était qu'un vieil
pour que s'améliorent d'année en année
il ya eu d'autres shows puisse aller
très très bon très bon shoot
monoparentales
le guetteur aide beaucoup beaucoup aimer
vraiment de mono parentales donc ça
c'est excellent c'est merveilleux que
j'encourage tout le monde à les lever
était vraiment bon micro et tabourets la
formule est simple et sied parfaitement
à louis josé houde qui se sert de sa
voix quand je pars je me trilles et non
diby reconnaissable entre tous ceux dont
je crois c'est elvis est attaqué dans
coeur c'est encore s'attendre à tout
d'un coup c'est ton histoire c'est ton
temps sur la cas ça ne regarde que toi
avec un souci de la musicalité qui
impressionne je suis
[Musique]
oui josé houde sera en résidence à
l'olympia jusqu'à la mi-janvier et part
ensuite en tournée partout au québec ici
mélanie boissonneault radio canada
montréal
[Applaudissements]